hey guys dr. Burke here I wanted to
answer a question that keeps coming up
will vegetable carbohydrates stop
ketosis okay so it is true that
vegetables are carbohydrates but the
question is do they turn into sugar fast
or slow there's a thing called the
glycemic index and that is the rate or
which speed at which something actually
affects your blood sugars I guarantee a
salad or maybe like a spinach salad with
celery when you eat that it is not going
to spike your insulin okay so some
people that start including more
vegetables let's say they're doing the
Atkins diet it's really high protein and
fat and yes the absence of carbohydrates
do induce fat burning but if you have no
vegetable types of carbohydrates what's
going to happen you're going to get a
lot of waste in your body and it's stuff
called ketoacidosis or your body's pH
starts going higher and higher and
higher there's nothing to flesh that out
so I want to read to you guidance
physiology what it says in page 927 okay
the effect of insulin lack on causing a
fatty liver calling causing the the lack
of insulin right when you keep insulin
very low since it costs a great increase
in the amount of store triglyceride in
the liver leading to a very fatty liver
so in other words you got to be careful
doing ketosis because all this fat
that's being mobilized from your fat
stores from your stomach it has to go
through the liver and go through your
bloodstream
if you don't consume the vegetable
you're going to end up with a fatty
liver okay and that's defeats our whole
purpose and sometimes when people do
this they all check their blood in their
cholesterol goes really really high
because they're not eating the
vegetables to counteract that
now some people are eating the wrong
type of vegetables they're doing corn
okay
corn is not a vegetable in my viewpoint
or they're doing a lot of cruciferous
but they're sensitive to it they're not
digesting that so they bloat the
bloating will stop the weight loss
okay so just switch up your vegetables
do something like a fowl or something
like that but the vegetable cleans
encounter acts a lot of the fat burning
that takes place and it prevents the fat
from accumulating in your liver the
other thing is that if you don't want to
do the vegetables then where are you
getting your potassium from from the
meat from the fat there's there's no
potassium in there hardly any at all so
you need I mean a tremendous amount so
were you getting your magnesium where
are you getting all your vitamins and
minerals that's where you get them from
the vegetable family okay
so don't worry about vegetables when
you're doing ketosis I think it's
essential and I'm actually I put a twist
on this it's like my version of ketosis
you go ahead and do that and you'll
actually end up with a healthy body
alright thanks for watching